Speaker 1: All right. Let's look at a few other
things that happened yesterday. George Santos
seemed to forget his own name on the floor of the
house multiple times. His name was called for a
vote on Speaker of the House on the fifth
ballot. He seems not to recognize his own name,
which is just funny because, of course, his
full name is George Anthony Devil there Santos.
And it raises a question of whether does he
even really go by George Santos? Normally,
maybe he goes by Anthony Duvall there or
George Duvall there or Anthony Sanders. I
don't know. But here he is. They call him
multiple times. Doesn't seem to recognize
they're calling him for a vote. The guy
to his right seems to tell him like, hey,
that's your name, sir.
Speaker 4: Santos.
Santos.
Speaker 1:
SARBANES okay. And they move on to Sarbanes, and
then he holds up his hand and yells out that he's
voting for McCarthy.
Speaker 2:
Jeffries You even.
Speaker 1: You even see
Matt Gates come by. Just kind of like,
what is it that is even going on here?
So just kind of weird. Everything about Santos
is strange. For all we know, he's used to being
called some other name. I don't know. And it seems
that he is continuing to struggle to sort of build
community in the House of Representatives. And
I don't really know the end game for Santos. The
first 48 hours are not sustainable. Running away
with a huge backpack, running away from reporters
who want to ask him questions. Sitting by himself
in the floor of the house, picking his nose,
not recognizing his own name. And it's all
just truly bizarre. But I also have kind
of like a morbid curiosity where, like, how how
awkward can this possibly get? And you all know,
I love awkward. So we're going ahead and going to
go ahead and follow that. And by the way, the lies
from Jorge Santos haven't stopped since he arrived
in Washington, D.C. Let's talk about that next.